all right welcome to the show we are
going to be admittedly taking a tour
today
through some really uh depressing
and horrible realities about what's
going on
in the country in terms of the
fragmentation or balkanization as we
might call it of the american right wing
there's going to be a lot of really
horrible and negative things we talk
about but i
i think it's important number one not to
lose sight of the bigger picture and
number two
to also be a little bit less depressed
to start with what is actually some good
news not only about the pandemic which
i'll get to in a moment
but about the direction of the country
and the majority of the country
understanding that this change that took
place
between the last administration and the
current one it's not trivial
it's not irrelevant it's it's really
having an impact on people we have
new data from an nbc news poll
that shows that the percentage of
americans who say the country is
generally speaking going in the right
direction has just about
doubled since donald trump left office
in january
the day after joe biden was inaugurated
so january 21st
only 20 percent of the country believed
that the united states was quote
headed in the right direction which is
often the way this question is asked in
polling
but that share has improved to
40 percent among adults during the
period april 17
to 20. and it it's it's actually
a crazy reality where we say hey
40 of the country just just more than a
third
percent of the country now thinks we are
going in the right direction
and this is a massive increase and we
should see that as a really good thing i
understand that that's a depressing
and incredibly low bar but understand
that
first of all if you thought the country
was going in the right direction under
donald trump
your disconnect from the real world is
so significant that it's not that
reasonable to think
all of those people are going to have
some awakening once just
a normal person takes control of the
oval office
and the sadder reality is that that
perspective
that the right direction was the one
under donald trump remains the case for
tens of millions of americans and that's
not going to change anytime soon so
when we look at these numbers if you
showed these numbers to people from many
other countries
and you said listen we had arguably the
most destructive and unhinged president
in the modern political era
and at that time 20 of the country
thought we were going in the right
direction
we removed him uh his party lost the
house in 2018
his party lost the senate in 2020 as
well we have someone who now has built
one of the best vaccination
distribution programs in the world in
joe biden
who passed covet stimulus and is on on
the path to doing some other things
we're doing great now oh and we still
only have 40
of the country believing that we are now
going in the right direction other
countries would look at that and they
would i don't know if they would laugh
or cry or feel pity or be scared or
whatever the case may be
but it certainly wouldn't make a lot of
sense so
there is no question that there's a long
way to go there's no quest
no question that the hyper partisanship
that we're experiencing
is going to create i mean listen the the
i don't think in modern
american political uh space
you would ever have 80 percent of the
country say we are now going in the
right direction
for partisan reasons for tribal reasons
etc
let's take some solace because there's a
lot of really bad stuff we're going to
be going over today and i'm warning you
about that
uh in the fact that it has doubled and
then the continued good news
as far as the pandemic goes uh the
continued
um uh improving jobs numbers and stock
market numbers and
and remaining low inflation over the
next six to eight months hopefully will
increase those numbers even further now
from the standpoint of just
understanding the trumpist perspective
on this question were we going in the
right direction then are we going in the
right direction now
trump supporters seem unable to just
accept the reality that trump was
historically unpopular trump never hit
50
approval he left with 29 approval
and joe biden is relatively popular
given the polarized nature of the
country mid to high 50s approval for a
president in the modern political
era dating back to you know the the
george w bush era
it's significant in that it's not that
common
trumpists live by anecdote i don't know
i went to a trump rally and everybody
there had a trump flag
it and also when i look on twitter joe
biden doesn't get that many retweets on
twitter
their anecdotal experience plus watching
what newsmax and fox news tell them
tells them it can't possibly be true
that the country is now more optimistic
that biden has higher approval than
trump trump losing in 2020 was
proof of how bad of a candidate he was
he was gifted a crisis
that for many other world leaders proper
handling of the pandemic
easily escorted them to a just
completely runaway reelection
trump had the incumbency advantage he
had voter suppression on his side and he
still managed to lose people
point to look at how many votes trump
was able to get
but they don't seem to realize the
number of people that were alienated by
trump and horrified by trump
led to record votes for joe biden as
well
and only half of that story seems to be
what they focus on
this is a number 20 percent to 40
percent going in the right direction
that if it continues is a good sign if
you ever feel
like you just don't have enough time to
read all the books you want to read
you have to check out one of my favorite
apps called blinkist blinkist takes
thousands of popular non-fiction books
and distills each one down into an
e-book
or audiobook that you can get through in
just 15 minutes where you're getting all
the key takeaways from the book
just imagine how you'll be able to
expand your horizons and knowledge
by being able to soak up all of the
important insights from
ten different books in an afternoon
obviously it's perfect for exposing
yourself to a new book
you otherwise wouldn't have time for or
you can use it to revisit a book you've
already read
or use it to preview a book before you
buy the full version and read it i
recently read a brief history of time of
course by the great stephen hawking this
is a book that i have been aware of for
so long and other things got in the way
and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video